and in those cases many filmmakers just
don't understand that that's what
they're getting into they think i got a
distributor
my life is saved my film is going to
make a lot of money and they're going to
market it
this is a hard topic for us to bring up
but i'm hoping maybe you can clear up
some misconceptions
we often hear that filmmakers aren't
making money from distribution deals but
at the same time we hear that you can
make great money working in distribution
can you can you help us understand here
well
yes
um
so
in my opinion
most people aren't making money
from distribution because most films
just don't work because the public
didn't
decide to click on
your movie they didn't buy a ticket
um
there's just a lot more
um
there's just a lot more content being
created by
the streamers and by studios that and
and we've got other ways of entertaining
ourselves in movies these days games and
tick-tock and whatever
that's there's just not a lot of as much
demand as
not a lot of demand compared to the
supply
at the end of the day
and so i find that
um
and distributors
are in the job of taking a cert out a
certain number of films a year
they know that some are going to work
they know by experience not all of them
are going to work and they're going to
do about the same thing on every film
maybe treating one a little better a
little bit more pna
uh you know more advertising dollars
behind it in order to make it work
and and they're gonna so they're gonna
take each one out and if one doesn't
work
it's gonna then
go through the motions of trying to get
a t you know if it didn't work in
theatrical
and or transactional vod like itunes and
amazon where people can rent and buy it
it didn't work there
they're still going to try to sell it to
hbo or hulu if they can if it doesn't
work there
then they're going to put it on
advertising video man demand channels
like 2b or pluto that pay small
royalties per view right and that's what
most that's the windowing that most
distributors do
and
there's not a lot to that
right it's just placement it's
salesmanship and placement and they're
not going to spit like if a film didn't
work in the very beginning they're not
going to keep spending advertising
dollars they're going to keep there's
not much for them to do
and i think filmmakers
feel like
you know hey you're not doing anything
for my movie well but should they be
doing anything for your movie if they
did more for your movie they would
probably lose more money
if the film didn't work on the outset if
it didn't connect in the first three
months of its life
it's it's
not going to make money and that's and
it's going to stay with that distributor
and they're going to put it through the
platforms properly but if they were to
spend more time and effort trying to
monetize it they would lose
and you wouldn't make any more money is
the reality
in addition
i think in general distributors are
pretty bad at communicating that
to filmmakers
i constantly am having to preach that on
their behalf
to my clients and other people in the
business because
um
i've gone on to
um
there's platforms out there where people
vent about
distribution right
and you know i see who they're who
they're venting about
and i know the i know you know and some
yes there are so there there are some
scumbags out there that no one should
ever go near
but there are some people they're
venting about on there that i know are
running honest businesses
and doing it properly
but they're just not going to
be your best friend forever
right they're not going to be the best
friend of the film forever they're just
going to do their job if it works great
if it doesn't it doesn't
i also find some some filmers just don't
understand their contracts when they get
into them
um
you know there are some distributors of
a certain level that are saying okay
we're going to put the film out
theatrically we're going to spend this
amount of money and here's a big check
and that's a great that's great and you
forget about that for a second but most
deals are with distributors that are not
putting up any money
and just going to take it out on the
various digital platforms and try to
sell off netflix and hulu later etc
um
and in those cases many filmmakers just
don't understand that that's what
they're getting into they think i got a
distributor
my life is saved my film is going to
make a lot of money and they're going to
market it without even talking to them
about marketing and sometimes these
contracts even literally say we're not
hiring a publicist we're not marketing
the film we have the option to but we're
not pledging to
and so if you go in thinking your
server's going to do one thing and they
don't do it then there's then you're
getting on you know some platform and
saying oh i hate so-and-so you know
um
and so that's why
i i see a lot of that that's not to
diminish the people that do get screwed
over there are there are companies there
are bad actors out there
but there are um
a lot of distributors that just i think
a
are doing the job properly if if
even if they are falling a little short
on the communication of why
the films are not working to their
clients
so it's kind of a
barring someone being dishonest if a
company is honest but but then you have
filmmaker a over here who feels like i'm
not being given attention and my movie's
just being shoved to the back it sounds
like there's just the communication is
just really broken and one is a business
person the other is kind of an artist
that's very possessive over there their
work yeah and they're not meeting in the
middle
yeah i think that's right and i think
and that's not to say i wish that
distributors could be a little bit more
communicative and a little bit more in
kind of in general
even the ones i like
um could be a little bit more um
responsive to phone calls and emails
from clients but um
i think to a certain degree
a lot of these companies are taking a
lot of films and they've got to kind of
move on to the things that work
and
not all filmmakers are
are personable nice people either
right you get some
filmmakers that have screws loose or
are have napoleonic complexes or
whatever they have
and
um
and and they're coming after them with
phone call after phone call day after
day and as a distributor like do i have
to deal with that or i don't i don't
have a contractual obligation to call
back a jerk
right
i'm going to move on and start working
i'm working just like i do any other
film whether he's a jerk or not i'm
going to do the same thing
right i'm just going to stop talking to
him because he's just wasting my time
right now most filmmakers aren't like
that but there are that does happen and
i think that because that happens that
also makes distributors
you know
a little bit more reticent to
be personable and and and and
communicate with their filmmakers in
case it turns into that kind of like
like why am i in this conversation with
this person who
i put their film out it's not making me
any more money to talk to them
about what's happening yes they're my
client but
um
what you know what is there to do at
this point
and the reality too is
hard about this too is that some of
these contracts are seven ten years long
right and so filmmakers quite often feel
stuck they're like they're not doing
anything with my movie i can't get it
back
well the problem there is what do you do
when you get it back
you're not get no other distributor's
going to take it
after it's been distributed by somebody
else
you're not going to be able to get
netflix or hulu or so so and so to look
at it
most likely they've already shown it to
them
and they've passed
um
if you get it back if they do agree
if they do agree to give it back to you
you're going to get extracted from all
these digital platforms that it's on
they can't just turn the hose over
to you and have the financials just
start go you have to pull it off
and then you have a hard time getting it
back on
because some of those some of those
platforms are like we've had this film
before x like like you know we don't
want old films
um
[Music]
and so it's you know and so
people end up putting on amazon prime or
you know kind of direct themselves and
it just sits there and doesn't make any
money anyway
so
most filmmakers should be if they can
moving on to the next thing at that
point what's my next project
how can i take whatever happened here
make some good out of it
and hype it towards getting my next
thing done
because once you've got once you've made
that distribution deal whether you're in
a good situation
or a bad situation
you're that's it that's your your film
is that's going to be the story of your
film one way or the other
um
it's kind of an illusion that you can
get it back at some point and and make
something out of it and that's why
in addition to
knowing who the buyers are
and being able to read and understand
contracts is
that's kind of where i come in
i know
who communicates well
i know who does the job properly and
what that job actually is
as opposed to what it is and can explain
that to the filmmakers so they know what
they're getting into
when we make the deal so we don't get
those calls two years later saying
you know why aren't they marketing my
film because they knew what going in
because i explained it to them exactly
what kind of situation they got
well you use the word illusion which i
thought's fitting because maybe they did
read the contract maybe you explained it
to them properly but there's an illusion
mine's going to be different i realize
it's going to be locked up for this but
this is different yeah and that's
nothing against the filmmaker it's just
we all think
our thing is 100
i've i've produced movies as well with
other
not myself alone but with other people
and um
and i've
i've gotten the spell i've been in the
bubble of like we made the greatest
thing ever you know this is gonna go to
whoever and um
so i unders i do understand that and i
do ha and i do have clients that despite
i explain it to them do come back to me
later and say like why aren't they doing
this like well if you remember this is
what we talked about you know it's not
quite like that for this film
should a filmmaker kind of take the
worst case scenario i know some people
don't like to operate like that but
it can help if you kind of take the
worst case scenario
stance you know you're looking at the
contract and thinking well
i know it says i'll be locked up in this
territory or whatever for seven years
but i'm sure it'll be fine
and maybe just have something in their
mind do i really want that
is this really for me
um
i think that
yes i think that
i think you can make an educated guess
on what the worst case will be based on
the habits of the company you're in bed
with to a certain degree
so because
you know most distribution agreements
don't have anything in them that says
they have to put out the movie either
right
sometimes we can build in clauses where
it says if you don't release it nine
months we'll get the movie back
but that's pretty easy to fulfill when
you throw it on amazon and it's released
per se right so it's hard to get a
distribute like never get a distributed
guarantee what will happen
i'm saying that because
if you
are
if you do get a deal with the
distributor
and you look back
on the last couple of years and you see
oh they've released all these films and
these this is how they've released them
there's a little more security that the
worst case scenario is that they're
going to release it like that
right they said they're going to put it
on all these platforms they did it for
all these other films so that's most
likely the worst case scenario and the
worst case scenario is that
they do that
and no one bothers to buy the movie
you know
that can happen for you know
lots of films
um
you know it doesn't happen at a certain
level if you're getting big theatrical
deals but we're talking about straight
to digital you know distribution
that's very much
but i it's funny because i've had
so many films now go to these
distributors that handle all rights
and they give them the same treatment
and some make a couple hundred thousand
dollars and some make two thousand
dollars
and you really can't
see any difference between the two
except that
perhaps the artwork just clicked with
the public better the trailer clicked
someone said something about it kind of
organically online and that took off and
created a swirl it's really hard like
there's a lot of things you can tell a
filmmaker to try to do to support a film
publicity getting social media company
um doing a theatrical
there's nothing that guarantees that any
of that will help or work
um
i almost always do kind of if someone
just has has a digital distribution deal
say try to do something to help support
it because at least you feel like you
did something
um
but there's no real empirical evidence
that like having a publicist for a film
makes a dollar more
um or that running five thousand dollars
in social media ads makes ten dollars
more
um
at least from what i see in terms of
looking at films i've seen many films
get no treatment make lots of money and
some don't